un llamado de atención al mundo sobre la
situación de las afganas previo al
cierre de la sesión de las 76 asambleas
general de Naciones Unidas activistas
aduanas en el exilio alzaron la voz para
denunciar las violaciones a los derechos
que padecen las mujeres y niñas en
Afganistán desde la toma del poder de
los talibanes en agosto de 2021 y
reclaman acciones internacionales firmes
contra el gobierno Lady saintman lo que
está ocurriendo en Afganistán señoras y
señores es una parte de género
claramente una parte de género no soy la
primera en decirlo pero la inacción de
la comunidad internacional y de los
responsables de la toma de decisiones en
general hace que sea importante que
todos nosotros lo repitamos Afganistán
es una parte de género
la guerra en Ucrania la inflación
mundial o la crisis de alimentos acopado
las reuniones del último año en Nueva
York relegando Afganistán a un segundo
plano mientras los talibanes incumplían
sus promesas respecto a las mujeres que
finalmente han quedado recluidas en sus
hogares sin poder acceder a la educación
trabajar y obligadas a ocu bajo el burka
estoy profundamente preocupado por la
asombrosa regresión en el disfrute de
los Derechos civiles políticos
económicos sociales y culturales de
mujeres y niñas desde que los talibanes
tomaron el control del país
según Naciones Unidas unas 850,000 niñas
y han visto forzadas a abandonar la
escuela quedando en riesgo de ser
sometidas a matrimonios forzados o a la
explotación económica o sexual entre
tanto el gobierno talibán sigue pidiendo
un reconocimiento que hasta ahora la
comunidad internacional le niega